hello again everyone
so thank you for continuing on through
this session
thank you sandoro for an excellent talk
i want to make one point a clarification
in the logistics here
there have been some questions that have
been raised for sandro and
if you have more questions for his talk
continue to put those
in the questions uh box at the lower
left
of your screen and at the end of the
the next talk we're going to have a
joint question and answer
uh session sandra will be live with me
and the two of us will answer
questions the next talk is actually from
me
um and so uh i
am just a brief introduction but i'm an
assistant professor at
harvard medical school in the department
of microbiology as well as
in the program in cellular molecular
medicine at boston children's hospital
and as you'll see in this talk my
laboratory leverages
multiplexed rna imaging which is a nice
complement to the protein imaging
that sandra just discussed to get at the
same types of questions
the identity of cells and their spatial
organization in tissues
and so i think this provides a nice book
end
where you can now see how multiplexing
has been improving
in both the protein space and the rna
space
and so again we'll have all our
questions for both talks after
this talk
good afternoon everyone my name is jeff
moffitt
and i just want to thank the entire
organizers
for this opportunity to be a part of
this session
so i'm an assistant professor at the
program in cellular molecular medicine
at boston children's hospital
and in the department of microbiology
harvard medical school
and today i'm going to tell you a little
bit about a core technology that i
co-developed as a postdoctoral fellow
and which is a major driving force in my
laboratory
this is a technology known as
multiplexed aero robust fluorescence in
situ hybridization
or murfish for short and in a nutshell
it's an approach that allows us to image
and identify hundreds thousands or now
tens of thousands of different rna
molecules
simultaneously within individual cells
in fixed
tissue samples and because of that we
can now do spatially resolved
single cell transfer comics and use
these measurements
to both discover and define cell types
and states while mapping out their
intricate spatial organization in intact
tissues
so today i'm going to tell you a little
bit about how this technology works how
it performs
i'll give you just a taste of the wide
variety of biological applications that
we are now tackling with this
and then i'll dive relatively deeply
into one i think very evocative
application
the use of this technique to discover
and map cell types in a portion of the
mouse brain
before i go too far though i want to
acknowledge that i'm a co-founder and
stakeholder
in a company that aims to commercialize
the murafish technology
that companies known as visgen though no
products or services of this gen were
used
to produce any of the data or results
that i'll present here today
so why would one want or need spatially
resolved
approaches to single cell
transcriptomics well i'm sure you're all
very well aware
of the revolution that we've seen in our
understanding of a wide variety of
tissues
driven by our ability to dissociate
capture and sequence individual cells
using technologies such as single cell
rna sequencing
so we can now take any complex tissue
dissociated
into individual cells extract from those
cells the rnas the express
and then quantify their expression at
the transcriptome scale using next
generation sequencing
that in turn has allowed us to now
discover and catalog cell types
in almost every organism and tissue
but in the process of dissociating these
cells and extracting these rnas we lose
important insights so we lose insight
into how the rnas are organized within
the cell
and that organization can be a very
potent form of post-transcriptional
regulation
that drives a wide variety of biological
phenomena in addition we lose insight
into how these cells are
actually organized within the tissue and
as we know
tissue organization plays an intricate
role in how
individual cell types communicate with
one another and how the behavior of the
tissue as a whole emerges from the
behavior of the individual cell types
and states that comprise it
and so what we wanted to do was to
develop technology that had the
strengths of single cell rna sequencing
but could preserve this spatial context
and that's what we've done with merfish
so murfish is based upon a very powerful
technology known as single molecule
fluorescence institute hybridization or
fish
in this approach you fix your sample
permeabilize the membrane of the cells
and then hybridize to it a set of
fluorescently labeled dna oleg and
whose sequences are complementary to
different regions of the rna of interest
this concentrates a large number of
fluorophores in each and every molecule
of that rna
such that when you image this sample
with an epi fluorescence microscope
you now see bright fluorescent puncture
for each molecule this allows you to
count the number of molecules per cell
and of course see their organization
within the cell and
the organization that sell within the
context of the sample as a whole
so our goal with murfish was to take
this powerful technique and multiplex it
we do so by assigning to each rna a
unique binary barcode and then we read
out those barcodes in the following way
we state our sample using fairly
conventional single molecule fish
approaches
but with one important distinction
instead of targeting a single rna we
talk at every rna that has a one in the
first bit of the barcode
we get an image like this we'll remove
this signal now restain the sample
targeting every rna that has a one in
the second bit of this bar code
we'll get a different pattern of
fluorescence which we will then image
and extinguish
and we'll repeat this process for each
bit in these barcodes
such that the fluorescence on off
pattern we see across the stack images
defines the barcode and thus the rna
now one of the important features of
this is that we also
leverage bar coding schemes that allow
us to detect
and correct when individual errors can
happen so not only can we
identify large number of rnas via the
large number of barcodes produced by
this method
but we can do so with very high fidelity
as i'll show you here in a slide
so here's an example of an actual
murfish measurement what you see here on
the left
is an image of a human osteosarcoma cell
culture
after the first round of murphy's
imaging each bright fluorescent spot is
a single rna molecule
we can zoom in on one small portion of
one of the three cells you see in this
image
and you can see that one molecule is
present which gives us a one in the
first bit
we remove this signal resame the sample
other molecules are now fluorescent but
this molecule is no longer fluorescent
giving us a zero on the second bit
we do this again and the third bit this
molecule is now fluorescent again and i
think at this point you get the idea
in this case we'll do this 13 more times
to build up a stack of 16 images
this molecule is on the first the third
the eighth and the thirteenth image
giving us the barcode that you see here
we have this barcode or similar barcodes
i should say
for all of the 140 different types of
rnas stained in the sample
allowing us to reconstruct an image like
this where each marker is in rna
and the color is its identity and so you
can see that these
allow this approach allows us to
optically barcode and identify
individual rna molecules
and we've died we've extensively
benchmarked this technique so we know
that it now has a large dynamic range
near 100 molecular detection efficiency
and faithful detection even of a single
molecular copy
per cell and by increasing or changing
the length of these barcodes we can
tune the multiplexing the demands of our
specific question
we can identify hundreds of thousands or
now 10 000 different mrnas
simultaneously within individual cells
using merfish
because this is an imaging technology
and imaging can be quite rapid
we can actually perform these
measurements in tens if not 100 000
cells
in each measurement so this can be a
very high throughput technique as well
so with this ability to do massively
multiplexed single molecule imaging
within individual cells
we can now ask a pretty broad range of
questions for example
we can use the natural variation in gene
expression from cell to cell
to identify sets of genes that co-vary
and thus are likely co-regulated
so we can identify or delineate
regulatory modules
we of course know exactly where each and
every one of those copies was found
within the cells
we can map the internal organization
transcriptome and we can do this in a
wide variety of
cell types states we can use the fact
that gene expression is a faithful
measure of the state of the cell to
infer
properties of that cell not just type
but state
we can also use this technology to
measure synthetic rnas not just native
rnas and these synthetic rnas can serve
as bar codes that allow us to identify
individual cells for example
cells that carry different genetic
perturbations and so this opens up a
wide variety of exciting biotechnology
applications as well
and then finally we can use the gene
expression measurements we have for
individual cells
to define their type and their state and
in many cases discover
unanticipated types and states all while
mapping their intricate organization and
tissue
and it's this application i'm going to
primarily focus on for the remainder of
my talk
so i'm going to tell you about a
published application of murfish for
discovering and mapping cell types and
states this application
was from the mouse brain in particular a
portion known as the pre-optic region of
the hypothalamus this was work done in
collaboration
with catherine dillock while i was still
a postdoc in chile sean's laboratory
now what you see here on the left is a
coronal and a satchel slice in the mouth
frame and the pre-optic region is the
region in the black box
and approximately in the region the
dashed line
now this is an interesting brain region
because it's responsible in part
for the control of a wide variety of
homeostatic functions so it has circuits
that control how
a mouse responds to hunger thirst or
fever
and it also controls higher level
functions that are nonetheless
non-learned social functions for example
how a mouse responds to an aggressive
perturbation or a situation that
involves mating
or parenting we know through the work of
a variety of labs that there are neurons
in this region of the brain
that comprise circuits that are
activated and in part control these
behaviors
but what wasn't clear was the diversity
of neuronal types that were found within
this region
and so we wanted to use murphish to ask
the simple question what are the
different types of neurons in this
portion of brain
and how are they linked to these
hypothalamic functions
but not just what neurons are there but
how are they spatially organized how do
they distribute
into the already defined sub-regions in
the hypothalamus that have been linked
to a variety of different hypothalamic
functions
and then can we go beyond just
identifying these neurons
based on their molecular profiles and
also mapping them spatially
to inferring their functional
organization into circuits
now morpheus is well suited for all of
these measurements but because this was
the first large-scale test of this
technology for discovery and mapping
cell types
we wanted to have an independent measure
of the cell type diversity that was
present there
so the first thing we did was dissect
out dissociate single cells
from the pre-optic region of multiple
male and female mice capture them
using the 10x chromium platform and
perform single-cell rna sequencing that
produced the data that you see here on
the left
this is a matrix in which individual
rows represent different genes
columns or different cells and colors
expression those genes in those cells
we can then cluster these cells using
standard statistical methods
and identify those clusters based on the
genes they express
and as expected we find all of the major
classes of cells so i'm going to
anticipate
in this portion of the brain we can then
visualize this high dimensional data in
two dimensions
using a technology known as t-sne where
each cell here in this 2d space for each
marker here in this 2d space is a cell
and it falls next to other cells
expressed the same genes the colors are
now indicated by the
clustering of these cells and we can
then take out our inhibitory and
excitatory neurons
marked here in red and yellow subject
into a second round of clustering and we
found
about 66 different types of neurons in
this portion of the brain
we then in parallel performed murfish on
exactly the same brain region taken from
different mice
we measured in total 155 different genes
with this technique
taken from three different categories
first category were classically defined
markers of major cell types so
genes that define inhibitory neurons
excitatory neurons oligodendrocytes
and so forth the second class of genes
were inspired by what we discovered with
our single cell rna sequencing and were
included
because they could discriminate
different neuronal types
but we didn't want to just define
neuronal types we also wanted to learn
something about their biology
and it's known from a wide variety of
prior work that neuropeptide and hormone
signaling is an important mode of
communication in the pre-optic region
and so we included in our panel a third
category of genes which was a
comprehensive set of neuropeptides and
neuropeptide and hormone receptors
and the receptors turn out to be an
important group because these are genes
that can be quite functionally relevant
even when expressed at very low levels
and despite its many strengths one of
the weaknesses of single cell rna
sequencing
is that it captures a relatively modest
fraction of what's actually expressed in
the cell
so it can be challenging to extract
statistically robust measurements
of these slowly expressed but
functioning relevant genes by contrast
murphy has single molecule sensitivity
so we hope we could do a better job here
what you see here on the left is a
result from a murfish measurement
we took a two millimeter by two
millimeter by six hundred micron block
after the pre-optic region
sectioned it into ten micron thick
sections sampled every
fifth section i read those on cover
slips and measure them with murfish
what you see here on the left is a 200
by 200 micron field of view from one
such slice
each white dot is again a single rna
molecule we would include with these
measurements
co-stains that will allow us to
automatically define the boundaries of
these cells that's what's marked in
white
and then we can color these rnas based
on their identity as determined by
more fish and i think you can
immediately see from this
image the transcriptional diversity that
is present
within just a small portion of this
tissue you have cells that are
expressing predominantly red rnas
green rnas blue rnas and so forth these
are
a visual representation of the molecular
fingerprints that define
different cell types now to give you a
sense of scale over which we can perform
these measurements
let's zoom back to a single two by two
millimeter slice that's what you see
here the white box is the field of view
that i just showed you
and now we don't have a color palette
that can accurately describe to ri 155
different genes
so i'm going to simplify this by just
showing you eight so we can walk through
the spatial distribution of just eight
different genes
collected in this single slice and i
think you can immediately see
the richness in gene expression across
these large tissue areas
and by leveraging the high throughput of
murfish we could in total
characterize gene expression in 1.1
million cells
with tissue collected from 31 different
animals and a total integrated tissue
area
of over 700 millimeters squared
because we have the boundaries of these
cells and the rnas that fall within
those boundaries we have an expression
profile for each and every one of these
cells
we can now analyze these using exactly
the same statistical toolbox developed
for single cell rna sequencing
so unsupervised clustering and tc
visualization that's what you see here
and what we found was that 155 genes
was more than sufficient to find all the
major classes of cells we expect to find
in this brain
as you can see here and now we could
actually ask a very interesting question
we've now characterized gene expression
in this region of the brain
using a technology that dissociates and
sequences cells
and one that images rnas directly within
intact tissue
both technologies find the same classes
as cells but to what degree do their
expression profiles agree
so we performed a pairwise pearson
correlation analysis
in this matrix each row represents
a cell type identified with murfish each
column
the comparable type identified with
sequencing and the strong diagonal here
indicates that
these two technologies agree very nicely
the fact these correlation coefficients
on this diagonal are all very close to
one
means that this agreement is actually
quantitative so it's a nice
cross-validation of both techniques
so murfish with 155 genes can define
these cell types
the advantage of course is that we never
dissociated the cell so we get an atlas
of this tissue
essentially for free that's what you see
here each black box is a two by two
millimeter slice
there are twelve slices taken from a
single animal and they are arrayed from
the anterior to
posterior portion of the brain left to
right the gray boundaries
mark individual cells you can help color
these cells based on the identities
determined by the expression profiles
as measured by merfish so here are our
inhibitory neurons
our excitatory neurons mature
myelinating oligodendrocytes
oligodendrocyte precursors microglia
astrocytes
endothelial cells neural cells
and ependymal cells these are ciliated
cells that drive the movement of
cervical spinal fluid
and you see that they form a single cell
layer flanking a structure known as the
third ventricle
filled with that fluid and so we can now
put back
all of these cell types to reveal the
intricate organization
of this portion of the brain from a
single mouse
now we can take our inhibitory
excitatory neurons as measured by
murfish
subjecting to a second round of
unsupervised clustering in this case we
find 70 different types of neurons
we can then do the same type of pearson
correlation analysis
with single cell sequencing that i
presented a few slides ago we see a nice
strong diagonal again
providing a nice validation in these two
technologies but we can go one step
further
and look to find a correspondence
between the neural types we find in
murfish
and neuronal types we find in sequencing
and we did the simplest thing one could
imagine
which is to pull out the largest and
statistically distinguishable
pearson correlation coefficients those
are the elements marked here in this
matrix
now what's nice about this is that we
find that the vast majority of the
neuronal types that we see in murfish
have a corresponding type in sequencing
that is a nice cross validation again
but one thing i want you to notice
is that this correspondence is not
always one to one there are instances
in which murfish is able to subdivide a
single neuronal type
that sequencing identified and what we
find in most of those instances
is that these subdivisions are defined
by the expression of
lowly expressed but functionally
relevant
receptors and so the sensitivity of
murfish allows us
to discover cell types that we were
incapable of discovering
with the statistical approaches that we
used with single cell sequencing
we can also take a look at the spatial
distribution of these neurons here again
we see our 12 slices per animal
array left to right gray are all cells
and red green and blue
mark three of the more abundant
inhibitory neuronal types i want you to
see that these patterns are bilaterally
symmetric
and that they change in striking ways
over relatively short distances
along the anterior posterior axis these
patterns are also nicely reproduced
across replicated animals
and i don't want to go here into the
details
of what these spatial distributions mean
there's a lot that they tell us about
the organization
and the principles of organization
hypothalamus but what i want you to take
from this
is that if we look at nine different
types of the 70 types of neurons that we
found
they all have their own unique spatial
distributions so there's a remarkable
spatial richness
in this small portion of the brain
now i want to tell you about one last
experiment we did in this work
what we did is we took a female mouse we
added a pup to its cage
it turns out that that mouse will
actually go and retrieve the pup bring
it back to its nest and care
for it even if it's not its own pup
that's called the non-learned or
instinctive parental behavior
after that behavior we then sacrificed
the mess and performed murphys in its
brain
and included one extra gene in our panel
this was the gene c-phos which is
rapidly expressed in neurons
after activity we clustered and found
all of our semi-type of neurons and then
looked to see which of these neurons
were expressing c phos what you see here
is a bar for each of our neurons
and the height of that bar indicates the
enrichment in cfos
expression what we find is in these
virgin female mice that have just
expressed this parenting behavior
there's one and only one type of neuron
with a statistically significant
enrichment in cfos
we can now do exactly the same
experiment but in male mice
and the results are strikingly different
those mice will often kill those pups
what we find is they have a different
set of neurons that are now activated
now we can do a very interesting
experiment we can take a male mouse
three weeks after it's sexually
experienced
it will now care for those pups exactly
like female mice will
now what we see is that this parental
neuron is activated
in the background of an activation
pattern reminiscent of the aggression
and so i think you can get the point
here we can now stimulate these mice
with a variety of
known stimuli that trigger hypothalamic
functions and now systematically go
through and functionally annotate the
neurons that we've discovered
and one point i want to make here is
that the neurons we find that
discriminate aggression and parenting
were not separately clustered in our
sequencing data these are defined
by a handful of lowly expressed
receptors and we only see these neural
types
in our more sensitive or fish
measurements
and so that i want to just leave you
with a sense of murfish murphish is a
massively multiplexed single molecule
imaging technique that
functions by taking a series of images
all of the same sample in which
different subsets of rnas are less
simply labeled in each image
such that across the stack of image each
rna has a unique fluorescence on a
pattern that serves as a barcode that
identifies it
we can bootstrap this technology to
the multiplexing of hundreds thousands
10
000 different mrnas so near
transcriptome scale measurements
we can do so with very high performance
near 100 detection efficiency
very low detection limits and large
dynamic ranges and we can quantify tens
of millions of rna copies in tens of
thousands of cells per day at a cost of
less than a fraction of a penny per cell
and we can use this technology to now
create molecularly defined atlases of
complex tissues
for example in the hypothalamus we
created such an atlas in the preoptic
region
we used this atlas to discover really a
striking
diversity of neuronal types in such a
small portion of the brain
and to map them out and to functionally
annotate them
and the spatial organization that we
observed has very interesting
implications for both the circuits that
are present in this region of the brain
as well as a developmental process that
gives rise to them
the last point i want to leave you with
is the fact that the technologies that
we developed and used in the brain
are not specific to the brain and so
that means that murfish can be used to
create similar molecular defined atlases
in a wide range of tissues which is
exactly what my laboratory
is now doing so with that i want to
thank say thank you to all the people
who are involved in this work
mainly the work that i presented here
for all of the work that i presented
here today
was directed my postdoctoral time in
shawway's
schwalms laboratory and the tissue work
was all a close collaboration with
catherine delox laboratory
we had a really great group of people
working on these projects uh stephen
eichorn dj bombamoku and eric von were
involved in the tissue work
and then how aleister stephen junjie
ping tien hazen and george
were all heavily involved in different
aspects of murphy's development
and we had some excellent help in
clustering from karthik
shakhar and navid regislam i also want
to thank
members of my new laboratory who have
been helping me get this technology
established
at boston children's and harvard medical
school and are now using this to tackle
a wide range of questions
and i look forward to telling you about
those results sometime in the future
so thank you very much for your time and
attention
all right so now we're going to open
this up
to questions
again if you have any questions that you
haven't asked
there should be a option for you to
add those questions to the list in the
lower left
of your uh window there
and so sandra will be joining us here i
think in a moment to answer a few
questions but
uh in the meanwhile
uh i will go ahead and start with a
murphish question
so we have a question from the audience
that reads does murphy require
fresh brain and can it work with frozen
human brain
so the answer is that a murphy is
actually a very general
technology it can work with a wide
variety of different
um preparation methods we have worked
with
freshly frozen brain as well
as um heavily fixed brain
but it does require fixed tissues
because you are repetitively imaging the
sample so you need to have
molecules that are anchored in place
great uh so sandra there are a few
questions here for you you hear me jeff
yes i can hear you now great and so
um i'll just start at the bottom
do you perform a strip and reprobe of
tissues so you can obtain
all the cell types in one single site
and then there's a nice compliment to
say that the images are impressive which
i completely agree
thanks jeff um so so the method um
it's fairly straightforward we we
incubate with antibodies
the standard way is three antibodies and
then after imaging we we photobleach so
the antibodies remain
uh attached to the tissue and then we
reapply an additional
three antibodies and continue with
cycles of application
and then photobleaching so there's no uh
stripping per se although some methods
um that are similar to this one use
stripping
we find that that is a little more uh
rough on the tissue and leads to
these the tissue degradation so we we
prefer the photobleaching method
we are expanding from three to four
antibodies now and up to out to six per
cycle so that's another way that we
we can increase the the throughput of
the of the assay
great so um center here's another
question for you
uh this is a really good one it's a
question that actually applies to both
technologies but
how does one go about analyzing these
gigapixel multi-channel images
uh you know i'm going to add that
question can you
just comment uh a typical saisif
measurement
what is the size of the raw images that
you collect here
yeah so so um we um
we do whole slide imaging so there is
there's a lot of data
there can be in you know one slide there
could be up to a million plus cells
so um in in one of the three-dimensional
reconstructions we showed that's that
data set there is a couple of terabytes
of
of of data so it's it's quite large and
i'm sure
we don't maybe maybe we don't rival you
jeff but it's it's a lot it's just a lot
of information
um so how do we go about analyzing these
images
um i i think you can think about this in
two broad ways there
is commercial software that's available
uh companies like halo
indica labs halo visio farm they have
software that's available
because we're really into the nuts and
bolts of this and developing the methods
kind of the way jeff is with his
technology we really make all of the
pipelines customized so if you're
interested you can find
these pipelines on github most of it's
written um
using matlab essentially and there you
can think of it broadly in terms of
pre-processing where we have to stitch
together these images and do
do artifact correction using a program
called ashlar and another one called
basic
then we do segmentation generally there
are a whole range of ways of doing this
again it's a whole
important scientific area of discovery
but we use a machine learning based
bio image analysis tool called elastic
which is really great
we generate segmentation masks then do
single cell calls of
fluorescence intensity and then it goes
on i mean it just goes on and on and on
from there in terms of cell type calling
um neighborhood analyses there's really
a there's really a lot to it and we can
go on indefinitely but i
i invite you to look at our at our
github the santa gada lab github the
lab of systems pharmacology github with
peter sorger and also a few of our
papers
uh in e-life nature protocols and nature
cell biology which will get you
a good view of how this works but it's
it really i don't i jeff i mean
this for us this is like our main thing
i i think
the the key thing is the underestimation
uh
in terms of the amount of computational
time and effort that's required
the acquisition is really rather
straightforward in comparison
yeah i would completely agree that what
is exciting about these
extremely multiplexed images uh is the
amount information you get
from them but you have to you have to
computationally extract that
it's a non trivial problem it's not
solved
and uh i think it is a place that needs
a lot of active research
a place where innovations can make a
huge difference absolutely
jeff should i ask you a question from
the list list so
so there's one that says is there any
limit for low abundancy transcript
transcription uh transcripts
sorry yeah so in murfish they're they're
um they're in practice is no limit we
have
in every measurement we include a series
of bar codes that could identify rnas
yet we don't so those serve as an
internal control that measures our false
positive rate and
that will vary slightly from measurement
to measurement but it's consistently at
a level of
uh less than a fraction of a transcript
per cell
so that means that if you count a single
copy of a transcript you can actually
trust that measurement and so um
you know this false positive rate does
affect our ability to infer
average expression that's much less than
one copy per cell
but for most single cell analyses you
know
that that's not really the level that
you're you're being able to extract
statistically
robustering from interesting information
and
how about related to that there's a
question about uh rna isoforms and then
the ability to detect smaller small rnas
micrornas
yeah that's also an excellent question
and so
uh the way that single molecule fish in
general
performs is you will tile an rna with
multiple orthogonal probes each
targeting a different region
that's actually very powerful because it
means that if any individual probe does
not bind because there's
occluding protein or secondary structure
in the rna
well then you still have the other
probes that bind you get a robust signal
and it's one of the reasons why we can
detect and perform so well in in
a variety of samples but it also places
a limit on
the length of rna and so we can go quite
short a couple hundred nucleotides but
things where you could really only fit
on one or a couple probes
are going to be challenging for our
current implementation these techniques
though we're working on this okay hi
jeff i think um
i think it's time for us to wrap up is
the all right
i'm seeing that as well um well everyone
it looks like we are out of time and uh
there are some
uh additional sessions that i i
i think i encourage you all to attend it
will be excellent and again i want to
thank
uh sandro for joining us here today and
for the organizers for putting together
what's really a phenomenal
set of talks so thank you everybody yes
thank you
bye